hey whats up guys so if you're following
me on Twitter you know i love the
Twitter machine and i'm putting out a
lot of stuff out there hopefully some
informational stuff hopefully i make you
laugh every now and again but i sent out
a tweet last night asking if you guys
had any questions for me we did one of
these a month ago and we got a crazy
amount of responses so i'm going to
answer some of your Twitter questions
and don't forget you can always follow
me on twitter at proven report that's
how you spell it right there alright
here we go here's horse one geez john
wants to know my favorite Star Wars
character okay everyone knows I love
Star Wars it would be cliche and easy to
say Boba Fett he's everybody's he was a
badass [ __ ] and he you know the
the carbonite and catching han Solo and
all that stuff um so I'm not gonna say
him and I'm not gonna say Han Solo who
also at least in the originals was by
far the coolest character I'm gonna go
edgy here I'm gonna take someone from uh
the prequels I'm gonna say this is this
is nuts i know this is not because he
was really only in one movie i'm gonna
say general grievous he led the droid
army and he wasn't fully fleshed out in
uh in this in the third movie but he
really was a great character this guy
who if you know a little bit about the
Star Wars lore really originally was a
sort of a good guy who became a bad guy
and sort of got duped by Count Dooku and
he was sort of a coward but he ended up
killing a lot of Jedi if you'd follow
some of the the cartoon network had that
cartoon not clone wars laid a cartoon
that took place between episodes two and
three you find out why he has the cough
it has a little something to do with
mace windu and he was just an
interesting character that they had and
he just looked really cool and you could
argue that the that his body you know
the sort of organic body with the robot
on top was sort of a first generation
darth vader so I really like General
Grievous and you know that Luke guy's
not bad too okay next do you have any
hope that this is eric wallace 117 do
you have any hope of the new Star Wars
being as good as the original three I
actually do have some hope I like the
prequels especially Revenge of this
and uh but obviously those were done by
George Lucas I have a feeling that
giving this into new hands with a new
fresh set of ideas also understanding
that there's going to be an expanded
universe and one offs uh being shot off
the originals I think that they can do
this right and uh I have faith and I
guess that's because I believe in the
force okay what's next crash matrix what
were the circumstances surrounding how
you got involved with tyt actually this
is a beautiful thing and it's fun funny
that we're talking about Twitter right
now because I connected with Kelly
Carlin you guys may know Kelly she's
been on my show many times she is an
author and she's she does comedy and
spoken word stuff she is the daughter of
comedy legend I mean really the god of
comedy George Carlin and I connected
with her on Twitter a couple years ago
ended up having her on my old siriusxm
show and then she connected me with
Malcolm here at the Young Turks to do
the point when it was the old point way
back when and I came in I was in LA
doing some other stuff and I came in and
I did one episode of the point I just
loved everything that was going on here
and I said to steve-o most of you guys
know Steve oh he's the COO and his
name's o of The Young Turks and the show
finished and he came up to me and he
said he was like great job Dave and I
was like I love to do a show with you
guys but I really was just kidding I
really was like oh somebody said
something Knightly I'd love to do a
showed you guys and he was like okay and
then yeah over the next like three
months I decided to wrap up my sirius XM
show moved out to LA and here we are all
right what's next uh Jared Williams are
you a fan of steven wright for those of
you that don't know Steven Wright he is
a legendary legendary comic really the
king of the one-liners you know just one
line punchline really slow incredible
delivery you can check them out on
youtube if you don't know who he is
aight you know when you do comedy you
sort of try everything or at least
that's how i did it that's how you kind
of find your voice so you can do more
animated stuff slow stuff I tried prop
comedy ones all kinds of so I did do one
set sort of in that Stephen right Mitch
Hedberg way of doing things it's not
really for me he's a genius I you
he's absolutely a genius and someone I
admire very much but my real real
influences would definitely be Cosby
would definitely be George Carlin would
be Ellen would be Bill Maher Andy
Kaufman uh those would sort of be my big
ones but I I do love Steven right what
else we got how did you find your
coming-out experience was it really
difficult or fairly easy I talked a lot
about this and actually we will put an
annotation right up here and a link in
the description down below I did a thing
with Ana Kasparian one of my best
friends and obviously co-hosts of The
Young Turks where we talked all about
that so you can click that right this
very second and that'll answer your
question what's next Joshua Fisher 89
what area of the country do you think
has the best beer I like this question
because I just started drinking a new
beer it's called eel river and it's from
Northern California I think Humboldt
County can anyone confirm that i think
it's around Humboldt County northern
california and it's an IPA eel river
totally dig it what's next Maddie Ryan
817 will you answer Golden Girls
questions yes Maddie I will what's next
Edward yyj favorite travel destination
outside of the USA I spent two stints in
Amsterdam I have almost no recollection
of both of them which means it was
pretty pretty good what's next Jimmy
shoes 1v how do you like your coffee uh
pretty dark pretty dark and a little
little cream I don't need the sugar I'm
off the sugar although occasion little
organic honey okay what's next Maddie
Ryan again mate 17 Dave what are your
thoughts on the increased anxiety levels
in Millennials due to constant exposure
news tweets Instagram you know we talked
about this on the show all the time we
are just living in this digital world
where we're constantly staring at this
thing I don't even think it's about
Millennials I think it's about people of
all ages because I'm not a millennial
and I've had to take time now last
weekend I basically took off the online
world and shut down Twitter the best I
could and I still ended up tweeting like
two or three times but I think it does i
think there's a lot of greatness about
it because it connects us you're able to
find people that think like you you're
able to get news from people that maybe
you couldn't have connected with first
but i do think this endless thing you
know instead you post an Instagram
for the next hour how many people like
it how many people liked it like I think
we are reinforcing some bad stuff um so
I hope we all learned how to deal with
it the best we can and that's
everybody's different some people have
more of an addictive personality you
gotta figure out how it fits into your
life it's something that I'm constantly
working on myself what's next chameleon
lost 88 why do people say I gotta take a
[ __ ] why wouldn't it be more accurate to
say I gotta give a [ __ ] I think that's a
good point and i will take that into
account what's next dierkes maximus one
have you ever found waldo i actually was
quite good at the Waldo books what's
next oh yes another in Turkish Maximus
one favorite hanna-barbera cartoon
without question the Jetsons you guys
know how much I'm into the sci-fi stuff
around here and it was just sort of a
perfect blend of sci-fi cool stuff a lot
of stuff that was sort of happening
right now and then comedy of course so
yes the Jetsons oh and one more for you
at Melissa Emmel in the last one of
these that we did she s what I would be
doing if i was in in comedy news this
whole thing and then I completely
answered a different question I read her
question and I just went on a complete
tangent so what would I be doing I I
have no freakin idea I have no idea I
might be in an office and be a really
frustrated tweeter that might be it i
might just have an office job i wish i
could be in the NBA but that's probably
not gonna happen uh what what could i
possibly be doing you know what I
probably be doing I'd probably if I had
gone like more of a sort of traditional
route I think maybe I would be working
in politics at some level maybe doing
like PR for a politician or you know
like a press secretary kind of thing but
then you're just spending a lot of
[ __ ] so I actually think I'm in the
right place anyway I thank you guys for
watching this and I thank you for
playing along on Twitter and on YouTube
and it's at Rubin report youtube com
site remember but you're watching this
right now so why don't even bother
saying that thank you and good night